MEREDITH KNOWLES: Land
O'Lakes is a customer
who collects massive
amounts of data
from farmers-- soil type,
rainfall, fertilizer amounts,
seed type, things like that.
But they didn't have a way
to bring that data together
to gain insight from it.
We were able to, over a
very short amount of time,
write an application
for them that pulled
that data into BigQuery
using Google Cloud Platform.
And so by doing that across
millions of acres of farmland,
farmers are being able to grow
more food with less input, less
resources, which is super
important for companies who
are looking to be more efficient
in the amount of resources
that they use to grow food.
And it also helps them, over
time, increase their crop yield
to feed our growing population.
[MUSIC PLAYING]